Japón tiene una relación con sus vecinos
de Asia Oriental un tanto especial… Por
no decir complicada o, incluso,tormentosa.
Aquí en VisualPolitik, os hemos hablado de
ello en varias ocasiones y la razón común
siempre suele ser la misma: las rencillas
históricas que una y otra y otra vez retornan
como un boomerang a la actualidad política.
Pero como siempre ocurre existen excepciones:
en concreto hay un país, que también sufrió
el pasado colonial de Japón, pero que sin
embargo tiene unas relaciones muy buenas con
el país del sol naciente. Dos países que
están forjando una estrecha alianza con importantes
implicaciones para toda la región.
Una alianza, no solo en el terreno económico,
dónde al final más o menos todos se entienden,
sino también en el aspecto político.
Y ojo, porque sorprendentemente hablamos de
Taiwán.
Y digo sorprendentemente porque no podemos
olvidar que detrás de todo, ojo avizor está
China. Para el gigante asiático cualquier
cosa que tenga que tenga que ver con Taiwán
se convierte en todo un agravio.
Y claro, China es el mayor cliente de la economía
nipona, las empresas japoneses tienen invertidos
más de 130 mil millones de dólares en inversión
extranjera directa en la República Popular
y los chinos suponen casi el 30% de todos
los turistas que cada año visitan el país
del sol naciente.
Así que, no se, a priori eso de arriesgarse
a sacar de sus casillas al gigante asiático,
pues, ¿qué queréis que os diga? No parece
una buena idea.
Pero, entonces: ¿Qué une exactamente a Japón
con Taiwán? ¿Qué ha llevado a Tokyo a querer
aproximarse tanto a Taipei? ¿Qué están
buscando?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo vamos
a responder a estas preguntas. Y sí, tal
y como muchos os estareis imaginando en toda
esta historia tiene mucha influencia la creciente
agenda nacionalista de Xi Jinping.
Pero, eso, eso no es todo. Los crecientes
vínculos entre Japón y Taiwán no se definen
únicamente por tener un adversario común,
en cierto modo hablamos de una alianza asentada
en cuestiones económicas, sociales e incluso
[para bien o para mal] en una historia compartida.
(Taiwán comparte con la China continental
la reclamación sobre las islas Senkaku, administradas
actualmente por el país del sol naciente.
Pese a ello, en la política exterior entre
Taiwán y Japón no existen resquicios de
hostilidad. Todo lo contrario.
Taiwán, que fue también ocupada y colonizada
por el Imperio de Japón, fue una de las pocas
colonias, si no la única, donde apenas hubo
resistencia interna a la ocupación. De hecho,
probablemente fue también el territorio ocupado
con mayor cantidad de colaboracionistas con
los japoneses.
Y todavía a día de hoy mucha gente en Taiwán
tiene un recuerdo dulce de la colonización.
Un periodo en el que Taiwán logró convertirse
en el territorio más rico de toda Asia Oriental,
si exceptuamos, claro está, al propio Japón.
Por ejemplo, durante ese periodo se multiplicaron
por 10 sus kilómetros de líneas de ferrocarril,
y los japoneses desarrollaron una destacada
potencia eléctrica en la isla para potenciar
su industria textil y química.
Y gracias, en buena medida, a ello, Taiwán
comenzó su industrialización mucho antes
que la mayor parte del resto de países asiáticos.
De tal forma, que la industria taiwanesa experimentó
un importante desarrollo durante la primera
mitad del siglo XX. Aunque luego la Segunda
Guerra Mundial supuso que la mayor parte de
la herencia japonesa se perdiera por completo)
Además, se puede decir que, a pesar de la
fuerte represión a la disidencia política,
las torturas y las ejecuciones sumarísimas
que siempre caracterizaban al imperio japonés,
Taiwán fue la niña mimada de entre todas
las colonias.
El caso es que toda esta historia compartida
explica en buena medida que Taiwán -oficialmente
la República de China- tuviera muchas menos
dificultades para establecer relaciones diplomáticas
amistosas con el Japón de la post-guerra.
Unas relaciones que han unido a estos dos
países en una especie de simbiosis tan acusada
que para muchos Taiwán es como una especie
de hermana china de Japón.
pero ¿Qué intereses unen a Japón con Taiwán?
¿Hacia dónde están avanzando las relaciones
entre ambos países? ¿Habrá cambios en las
políticas de Japón hacia China, en favor
de Taiwán?
Pues..Atentos.
(LA AMISTAD JAPÓN-TAIWÁN: ¿INTERÉS MUTUO?)
Sobre el mapa pueden parecer muy lejanos,
pero lo cierto es que a menos de 110 kilómetros
de distancia se encuentra el punto más cercano
entre Japón y Taiwán, en concreto, la isla
de Yonaguni. Y poco más lejos, a unos 220
kilómetros, está la isla de Ishigaki, donde
Japón está pensando en construir la base
militar más próxima a la China comunista.
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien. Japón ha
decidido construir una importante instalación
militar a poco más de 200 km de Taiwán.
Todo una carta de intenciones.
[¿Os imagináis que hubieran decidido montar
una base tan cerca de Corea del Sur. La que
se hubiera liado]
Pero luego hablaremos de este tema con más
detalle.
El caso es que los taiwaneses lejos de enfadarse
o sentirse amenazados están encantados. Seguro
que todos os imaginais, por que.
Con todo, sigue siendo llamativo que Japón
está haciendo semejante gesto. Y para os
los que os lo preguntéis, no, Japón tampoco
reconoce oficialmente a Taiwán.
(Junio de 2021: Japón dice que los lazos
con Taiwán son solo no oficiales - Business
Standard)
Claro que eso no ha sido obstáculo para que
desde que Japón dejó de reconocer oficialmente
al gobierno de Formosa los lazos entre ambos
territorios no hayan hecho más que crecer.
(En 1972, Japón dejó de reconocer formalmente
a la República de China, que es como se llama
oficialmente Taiwán, para pasar a reconocer
a la República Popular China como el gobierno
legítimo de toda China.
Sin embargo, estos guiños hacia la China
comunista que estaban llevando a cabo la mayor
parte de países del mundo, en realidad no
tuvieron ninguna consecuencia sobre el terrerno.
Las empresas siguieron deslocalizando producción
hacia Taiwán aprovechándose de la mano de
obra relativamente más barata, y logró un
posicionamiento muy importante en su tejido
industrial.
Y no solo eso. Japón también estuvo presente
en Taiwán como uno de los principales inversores
durante la transformación industrial que
experimentó Taiwán en los años 70. Taiwán
pasó de las fábricas textiles a las petroquímicas,
y en la década de los 80 y 90 logró desarrollar
una potente industria IT, en especial de hardware,
y muy concretamente de semiconductores. En
todos estos casos el capital japonés fue
decisivo)
Curiosamente en este último campo, Taiwán
ha logrado ganarle con holgura a Japón. Es
el país de Formosa el que ahora lleva la
delantera, hasta el punto de que podría darse
el escenario contrario al que históricamente
se dio:
La deslocalización industrial de Taiwán
a Japón.
(TSMC valora abrir en Japón una fábrica
de chips en 2023 para surtir a Sony - Nikkei
Asia)
Para los que no lo sepáis, TSMC es el mayor
y más avanzado fabricante de semiconductores
de todo el mundo. Y sí, es taiwanes. Los
semiconductores son la clave, el eje central,
el corazón y el cerebro de las nuevas tecnologías.
La robótica, la nanotecnología, la conducción
autónoma, el 5G o los sistemas militares
modernos. Todo depende de los semiconductores
y Taiwán es el gran líder mundial. Y claro,
si no quieres dejar que China se convierta
en el líder único e indiscutible de la región,
la tecnología juega un papel clave. En este
aspecto una mayor integración económica
entre Japón y Taiwán podría tener enormes
ventajas geoeconómicas.
Juntos, ambos países estarían muy bien posicionados
para liderar la carrera tecnológica en la
región. Con todo lo que ello implica. Y,
ojo, porque esto puede resultar clave para
el futuro de Asia-Pacífico y sobre todo para
el papel de Estados Unidos en esta zona. No
vamos a negar que tanto Japón como Taiwán
son grandes aliados de Washington.
Así que dicho y hecho. La integración entre
ambos países es cada vez mayor.
Otro ejemplo, en materia de infraestructuras,
a principios de 2007 se puso en servicio el
primer ferrocarril de alta velocidad de Taiwán,
y tanto sus trenes como su red y tecnología
fueron directamente importados de Japón.
De hecho, los trenes utilizados para la línea
de alta velocidad, del modelo THSR 700T y
fabricados por un consorcio entre empresas
filiales de Kawasaki, Hitachi y Nippon Sharyo,
son una versión adaptada de los Shinkansen
japoneses.
Y, por supuesto, también adaptaron la tecnología
japonesa en la línea. Apunte: Esta fue la
primera vez que Japón exportó su tecnología
de alta velocidad a un país extranjero, y
como veis el hecho de que sea precisamente
a Taiwán no fue ni mucho menos casualidad.
La obra fue de una complejidad tan grande
que tendría espacio por sí mismo en Megaprojekts.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se construyó
al 100% desde cero y el 70% del recorrido
discurre por viaductos, Taiwán invirtió
16.500 millones de dólares en esa línea.
Eso sí, el 79% fue sufragado por la inversión
privada. Y muy importante [Tomar nota políticos
derrochadores del mundo]: Esta línea es una
de las pocas líneas de alta velocidad en
el mundo que son rentables: más de 8.000
millones de dólares de Taiwán de beneficio
neto en 2019. Unos 300 millones de dólares
americanos.
Pues esperad un momento porque evidentemente
hay más, mucho más.
En materia de defensa y geopolítica es donde
la relación entre estos dos países alcanza
realmente su culmen. Una unión tan fuerte
como informal, pero sólida al fin y al cabo.
Y es que, amigos, Japón tiene importantes
planes para Taiwán… o quizás para sí
mismo, pero da igual porque benefician directamente
a la isla reclamada por China.
Atentos.
(EL “PLAN ISHIGAKI”)
Fijaos un momento en este mapa.
Se trata de la cadena de islas Ryukyu, las
islas más occidentales de Japón, entre las
cuales hay una que tenemos que destacaros
en este vídeo: Ishigaki.
(Además de ser uno de los principales destinos
turísticos de la prefectura de Okinawa, al
margen de la propia isla de Okinawa, Ishigaki
es también una isla estratégica para Japón.
Situada a un paso de Taiwán y muy cerca de
la China continental, pero lo suficientemente
lejos como para no estar excesivamente expuesta,
Ishigaki podría ser la próxima fortaleza
militar estratégica de Japón.
Allí las Fuerzas de Autodefensa niponas planean
desplegar entre finales de 2022 y marzo de
2023 tanto misiles antibuque como misiles
antiaéreos, así como un contingente de entre
500 y 600 soldados para operarlos.
Todo esto con la excusa, LA EXCUSA [enfatizar]
de proteger las islas Senkaku o Diaoyu de
las provocaciones chinas.)
Sin embargo, la realidad podría ser diferente.
El hecho de tener un contingente militar tan
cerca de Taiwán ha sido visto por estos últimos
como un mensaje claro de protección al país
insular, al tiempo que protege al propio Japón
y llegado al caso podría ser incluso una
base de operaciones para los Estados Unidos.
(El plan de misiles de Japón en Ishigaki
ayuda a reforzar la defensa de Taiwán - Nikkei
Asia
Analistas dicen que el plan pretende defender
Taiwán tanto como Japón, ya que cualquier
ataque en la isla democrática podría rápidamente
extenderse a las islas japonesas sureñas
- la primera línea defensiva de Tokyo.)
Vale, Ishigaki no será la primera de las
islas Ryukyu en ser armadas con misiles. De
hecho, sería la cuarta, pero es importante
porque es la más próxima a China de entre
todas las islas que contarían con bases de
misiles niponas.
Y no creáis ni por un instante que este plan
es nuevo… La idea de fortificar Ishigaki
con misiles viene barruntandose en las cabezas
pensantes del gobierno nipón desde 2017.
Y ahora la cada vez más agresiva campaña
de provocaciones chinas en el mar de la China
Oriental y en el estrecho de Taiwán han movido
finalmente al gobierno nipón a dar el paso.
La idea es crear una especie de muralla de
islas fortificadas con misiles capaces de
repeler una hipotética invasión china contra
las islas sur-occidentales de Japón.
Ahora bien, pensadlo un momento. Si un país,
que antiguamente te ha colonizado, anuncia
que va a poner misiles a pocos kilómetros
de tus costas, lo normal sería protestar,
sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta lo suspicaces
que son con la cuestión territorial en esta
zona del mundo, ¿no os parece?
De hecho, eso es exactamente lo que haría
cualquier otra ex-colonia nipona… ¡Pues
no! En este caso no.
Puertas adentro las autoridades de Taiwán
han celebrado este pasó como toda una victoria
diplomática.
Pero, además del importante plan para instalar
misiles en Ishigaki, todavía hay más.
Como ya os hemos contado en el boletín semanal
de Patreon, sorprendentemente y a pesar de
los crecientes tentáculos de China, Taiwán
cada vez tiene más amigos a lo largo y ancho
del mundo. Y lo cierto es que muchas potencias
ya se mueven en direcciones molestas para
China, como por ejemplo pedir que Taiwán
sea incluido como miembro de la OMS, que es
exactamente lo que se acordó en el último
G7.
Pero hay países concretos que están teniendo
más que gestos discretos con Taiwán. Obviamente
hablamos de Japón. Fijaos.
(Japón elimina a Taiwán del mapa de China
en el libro blanco de defensa - Taiwan News)
(En una advertencia a China, el nuevo libro
estratégico de Japón menciona a Taiwán
por primera vez - Forbes)
(El Viceministro de Defensa de Japón dice
que Taiwán debe ser protegido “como un
país democrático” - CNN)
Sí, aunque pueda resultarnos increible, lo
cierto es que Japón se está posicionando
como la única fuerza en Asia Oriental aparentemente
dispuesta a hacer frente a China.
Una posición que se podría reforzar si finalmente
el país nipón cambia su Constitución pacifista
que le obliga a no intervenir en el extranjero.
Aunque eso todavía está por ver.
Pero la cosa no acaba aquí.
Muchos medios internacionales se han hecho
eco de un debate que está en el seno del
parlamento nipón: una Ley de Relaciones con
Taiwán propia.
Y es que veréis, en concreto se toma como
ejemplo la Ley de Relaciones con Taiwán aprobada
en 1979 por Estados Unidos, cuando el país
pasó a reconocer a la República Popular
China en detrimento de la República de China.
Entre otras cosas, la Ley sirvió para establecer
fuertes relaciones no oficiales, incluso relaciones
prácticamente diplomáticas con una embajada
americana de facto. Una “relación especial”
reglada por Ley, algo de lo que Japón hoy
por hoy carece.
Además, recordad que esta Ley estadounidense
también habla en términos de defensa, en
concreto su sección 2.b.4 dice lo siguiente:
(“Es política de los Estados Unidos considerar
cualquier esfuerzo para determinar el futuro
de Taiwán por medios que no sean pacíficos,
incluidos boicots o embargos, una amenaza
para la paz y la seguridad del área del Pacífico
Occidental, y de gran preocupación para los
Estados Unidos". - Sección 2.b.4 de la Ley
de Relaciones con Taiwán)
Obviamente, no sabemos si la idea de los legisladores
japoneses que presionan para tramitar una
Ley similar a esta incluye incorporar el campo
de la defensa militar o los boicots y sanciones
contra China. Pero lo que desde luego sí
busca es establecer una relación mucho más
estrecha con Taiwán en detrimento de China.
Y eso es todo un cambio en el tablero de juego
con Pekín.
Juntos ambos países podrían convertirse
en la punta de lanza de una nueva ola pro-democrática
en la región, con los recursos suficientes
como para atraer a otros países y contener
el creciente peso de China. Sobre todo si
tenemos en cuenta los lazos con Estados Unidos
y su peso económico y tecnológico. Sin ir
más lejos, la inversión combinada de ambos
países en I+D se aproxima a los 250 mil millones
de dólares anuales.
De momento, el primer gran cambio puede ser
la entrada de Taiwán en el CPTPP, el heredero
del acuerdo comercial transpacífico al que
recientemente ha solicitado unirse Reino Unido
y que está liderado, precisamente por Japón.
(Tsai establece una hoja de ruta para que
Taiwán se una al CPTPP. Taiwan News)
Quien nos lo iba a decir, el pasivo Japón
comenzando a liderar un aparente muro de contención
a las ambicioes de Pekín.
Claro que todo esto abre otro debate: ¿Puede
Japón intensificar realmente sus relaciones
con Taiwán sin poner en riesgo sus enormes
vínculos económicos con China? ¿Estamos
tal vez ante el primer ejemplo en Asia de
discurso duro contra las políticas nacional
imperialistas de Xi Jinping?
Ojo, que no son preguntas menores. De hecho
ese es precisamente el debate, tanto en Japón
como en los propios Estados Unidos: ¿mano
dura contra Xi Jinping?
De momento, puedes dejarnos tu opinión en
los comentarios. Y ya sabes, si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante no olvides darle
a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.